i
[Música]
ah
el petró es una divisa digital de
venezuela creada en el año 2017 por el
gobierno de nicolás maduro con la
intención de blindar la economía abrir
puertas a la inversión y derrocar la
hegemonía del dólar nació como una
cripto moneda pero no se mina y tampoco
es independiente el gobierno venezolano
sostiene que el valor del petró está
sustentado en la riqueza petrolera y en
los minerales del país el pedrosu
wallpaper indica que mantendrá un precio
estable de 60 dólares por token para
evitar especulaciones el gobierno
impuesto su uso como medio para cancelar
impuestos y otras obligaciones dentro de
venezuela sin embargo eeuu sancionó esta
moneda digital en 2018 las empresas
extranjeras de anillos a ver el gobierno
que nos van a transar con ella porque se
exponen a que les congelen sus activos
en el país norteamericano el petró hasta
ahora no ha tenido el auge que nicolás
maduro le tenía destinado en parte por
la poca confianza que le tienen no sólo
el cripto activo en sí sino al gobierno
venezolano artífice de su creación y de
su puesta en marcha
[Música]
la pandemia de coronavirus no solo ha
cambiado la forma en cómo nos
relacionamos o nuestras relaciones
sociales sino también cómo nos
relacionamos con el dinero el banco
central europeo- ha visto como en los
últimos meses la población ha dejado de
utilizar el dinero en efectivo para
utilizar mucho más las tarjetas por ello
ha empezado a lanzar una consulta
pública para analizar los pros y contras
de tener una propia moneda digital la
presenta el banco central europeo-
christine lagard cree que es momento de
estar preparados para que la zona euro
pueda lanzar su propia moneda digital
pero hay que analizar bien las
consecuencias para no castigar al
sistema financiero de aumento países
como china y suecia ya están preparando
sus propios proyectos de moneda digital
pero de momento el banco central europeo
no estará preparado hasta la primavera
de 2021 para ver si los países del euro
también podrán tener su propio proyecto
de euro digital
[Música]
china se convirtió hace unos meses en el
país del mundo con más avance en el
ensayo de monedas virtuales esto para
hacerle frente a la aparición de cripto
monedas que cada vez suman más fuerza y
que son bastante riesgosas porque no
cuentan con un respaldo institucional a
mediados de octubre
beijing concluyó un proyecto piloto de
johann digital respaldado por el banco
central el emisor distribuyó 50.000
sobres rojos a ciudadanos al azar cada
paquete tenía 200 yuanes digitales es
decir unos 30 dólares para los usuarios
no es algo tan nuevo porque este es un
método de pago digital que ya se usa
hace mucho tiempo en el mundo sin
embargo para el gobierno el asunto es
mucho más complicado que eso el durán
digital está diseñado para reemplazar el
efectivo en circulación y de paso tener
un mayor control sobre el flujo de
efectivo en el país asiático
[Música]